all right guys
bang bang i've got brad here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
absolutely good to be here nice to see
you for sure for those that didn't
listen to the first episode we did maybe
just give us a quick kind of two minutes
on your background
and uh what ripple does so uh
real quick i i've been in silicon valley
doing tech stuff for 23 years moved out
here at 97
kind of dot com 1.0 uh
always been kind of involved in leading
edge and hopefully not bleeding edge
uh stuff and the first job i had out
here was
uh rolling out the first cable modems in
the country
and then i was at yahoo for a bunch of
years i'm shortening this visit yahoo
for a bunch of years
and a couple other things on the
investment side of things joined ripple
five and a half
closing in on six years ago early days
of crypto
and uh i mean suffice to say it's been
just an incredible journey
both crypto at large but also seeing
you know ripple grow from having an idea
that the germination of you know how
we thought about you know applying these
technologies not
any kind of experimentation and
speculation but hey real utility let's
solve a problem let's be clear about who
our customer
is you know we now have publicly shared
we're doing you know
closing in on a run rate of kind of 10
billion dollars a year of transactions
across ripple net
about 20 of that through what we call on
demand liquidity which
are xrp enabled transactions we're
continuing to see a lot of growth
uh you know we can talk more about the
implication of kobe but that's
some of the high level things about 500
employees globally
and uh cranking along awesome
uh what exactly is ripple and ripple net
just for those that don't know that
sorry so ripple is in effect you know
when i say i grew up in kansas as you
and i have discussed once or twice uh
and uh when i tell my friends back home
in effect ripple the simple way to think
about it we're an
enterprise software company and we sell
software to banks financial institutions
payment providers
that enables them to do real-time
cross-border transfers
today you know we have different value
networks
it is i think very analogous to early
days of the internet where
sending an email between aol and
compuserve
you couldn't act that was not
interoperable they were disparate
networks and you couldn't
send messages between them the internet
comes along and technologies like tcpip
come along and smtp
and the ability to then have
interoperable data networks enable
things that we obviously
rely upon today in effect ripple's
trying to do the same thing to make
value networks interoperable
towards the vision of enabling an
internet of value what we call an
internet of value
and today the most painful part of those
non-interoperable value networks i think
is really in cross-border transactions
where you're going cross-currency across
network across
institution there's a lot of friction
there
uh you know i often have used an analogy
of
an airplane that uh if the fastest way
you want to move money today from san
francisco where i am
to london is to actually get on an
airplane and fly it there
you know that's just a crazy thing to
say in a world you can stream video from
the internet so
ripple is solving that problem ripple
net is the network of
banks and finance institutions that are
connected today they're enabling
you know i i don't know top my heading
it's 60 plus countries
uh where we have uh payment corridors
today
that continues to grow uh quickly and
yeah that's ripple and ripple net
awesome so the reason why uh we wanted
to talk
is the crypto regulatory environment
uh a nice way to put it might be that it
leaves a lot to be
uh desired um there is everything from
uncertainty and just kind of uh you know
the unknown
all the way to uh maybe some bad ideas
that are out there
so maybe just walk us through as uh the
ceo
of a company that is constantly looking
at both the united states crypto
regulatory framework but also
other countries and other regions how do
you kind of see where the united states
is maybe where does
it kind of rank against other people
good bad ugly just kind of give me your
your general thoughts to start
well so first of all look i i i don't
know if i said it up front but thank you
for having me on because i think talking
about this stuff is super important
for all of us to have kind of a common
understanding of where we are
and i also will say you know we talk
about the crypto regulatory framework
you know i think we do as you in your
question
identified have to parse like us versus
other you know it is specific to
geography
unfortunately the u.s regulatory
framework is not
it's really out of sync with what other
major economies are doing and
you actually see in a very positive way
sorry i didn't turn off some of my
distractions there
you see in a very positive way uh some
countries i'll highlight the
constructive way
the uk the uk has a very clear taxonomy
uh the what's called the fca the
financial conduct
uh financial conduct authority i think
took the
really took a lead on characterizing
what different
assets had should be viewed based on the
use case
and yeah i think that was that helped
everybody in the uk
know as they thought about crypto how to
use crypto how the
the rules for the road were clear uh you
know i can highlight a positive way what
mas has done in singapore
what fsa has done in japan uh
switzerland
uae these are all examples where there
are there's clarity
and what's frustrating is here in the
u.s you see
lots of different kind of constructs uh
you know i think you even tweeted about
this but there
there was a department of justice report
i don't know three or four weeks ago
and it listed uh like 70 to 80 pages and
listed eight
separate u.s regulatory bodies each of
them with a different view
about you know cryptos of property uh no
crypto is a commodity
no crypt is a virtual currency or no
could crypto be
a security in some cases and you know
like
for the u.s i think we celebrate the
leadership the u.s has had around the
internet of information
as we know it today and it's in part
because early on
back in the mid 90s there was a clear
regulatory framework that allowed people
to invest
with certainty with clarity and you've
had a lot of investment come in and a
lot of success stories that are you know
well known
without that here in the u.s i think
it's really hard
for the us to compete on a level playing
field
with what's happening some of these
other markets absolutely and when you
start to think about
in the united states let's start with
maybe the things that
uh seem off right or or just
there are decisions that have been made
or directions that were headed that um
you know might not be the best path what
falls in that bucket for you right so
not the things that are uncertain
or unknown but are there specific things
that you're like look you know
either you guys have a different view or
uh you feel like
other jurisdictions are at odds with a
certain direction that the u.s
regulatory environment is headed
yeah you know i'm going to answer that
question that you're going to think i'm
trying to dodge it i'm not i want to
give a preamble
uh oftentimes when i answer my
perspective on this i get
uh the the certain elements of the
crypto community are like oh brad just
hates on bitcoin
let me be clear i said this to you when
i was last on your show
i personally in my own account own
bitcoin i'm long bitcoin
uh i'm a believer period i also think
the best way for bitcoin and really all
of crypto for long-term success
is that we are intellectually honest and
talk about what are the problems that
might limit
success in the future and like one of
the things that i think is just
it is reality the fact supported is that
today
the the us has said the u.s security
exchange commission has said
bitcoin is not a security they've said
ether is not a security
and that has given them the good
housekeeping seal of approval
that allows entrepreneurs to say okay
great i can
i can build upon that i can invest in
that i can
uh i can do that with certainty for
ripple
because we use xrp in our tech stack we
will go and i've had this experience i
will talk to ceos of other companies and
they'll say well look
hey you know we need to we're not going
to work with
enabled ripples products enabled by xrp
until there's clarity there
you know there's over 150 companies
working in the xrp ecosystem
and you know without that certainty we
have given here in the united states we
have given
an advantage to two technologies in
bitcoin and ether
that are today by virtue of the mining
capacity
managed in china by a small number of
miners
we're we're really enabling china to
have an advantage these
i actually happen to think the chinese
communist party has been extremely
strategic like i think they have been
focused
on dominating next-generation
technologies what we saw happen with 5g
networks as an example
we lost the 5g race and i think we're in
danger of repeating that mistake
in the battle over what i'll just
describe as global financial
infrastructure and global payments
uh so look i think it's a long-winded
way of saying
we need a level playing field not just
for the
the many companies in xrp community to
compete effectively
uh but you know we need that for other
projects as well
i'm not trying to be just uh kind of pro
xrp but i'm trying to look at okay all
boats rise i want crypto to do well
yeah and i think part of it you know the
one difference i would make there is
like
there are a very few number but some uh
bitcoin being one of them
that there was no kind of hey you give
me money and
i will sell you uh this token right so
kind of the initial
distribution um was what many people
would call
quote fair distribution or whatever
terminology you want to use
the thing that i think you're
highlighting is for pretty much the
i don't know 98 or 99 of other projects
that
have some sort of business or commercial
use um
to them there's not a lot of clarity and
it almost sounds like it's not only just
the final like
security not security type uh
deciphering but also
maybe there's even uncertainty around
like the framework that will be applied
here
is that fair or do you feel like the
framework is
pretty defined and then the decision is
the undefined part
no i think both of those are hard to
find i mean
look i think early on you know there's
this kind of argument
that uh hey you know
bitcoin is super decentralized and
therefore
you know it can't be a security and you
kind of look at that you're like all
right so
let's help people understand how the xrp
ledger is decentralized and how it is
open source and you know frankly even
recently there have been there's been
things the xrp community have championed
from the open source ledger of the xrp
ledger that we have opposed that still
passed
and if that's not a definition of what
is you know open source uh
technology like i'm not exactly sure
what it is but i think there was a
perception that okay the first
framework was decentralization and that
meant that bitcoin got the good
housekeeping how seal approval
and then not that long after ether got
it and then there was
that stopped and then it's like well
maybe decentralization isn't the right
things i think
you know once you kind of educate people
about how the xrp ledger works you're
like all right
uh you know let's
okay let's yield the xrp ledger is also
decentralized
well it's like okay do people
own different amounts and therefore that
it's different and
i just think it has been hard and some
of the things that have been published
that are you know intended to
make it clear are frankly really long
uh kind of frameworks that he's like
okay i don't
know i'm pretty educated about all
things crypto and i read these things
i'm like all right wait a minute you
know i'm not exactly sure how to do
how to think about this and look i go
back to what i said earlier it was just
recently
that the doj came out with this report
on cryptocurrencies
and in talking in some ways how they can
be used for illicit purposes but
when just recently you're talking about
eight separate us regulatory bodies
you know it just makes it hard for
companies in this space to operate
for sure i actually last time i'm
assuming your answer has not changed but
your belief and the people at ripple's
belief is xrp is not a security correct
me if i'm wrong on that
um but what would the
challenge to the business be if it was
deemed a security
right so like i always think of it as
like there's almost like this path where
you say okay
your belief based on whatever frameworks
are out there is xrp is not a security
uh if that ends up being the end state
you get the kind of you know the
housekeeping that you described
uh i think you guys have like a pretty
clear path as to like what you'll
continue to go do and accelerate and
kind of
the positive impact on the business
what's the impact
if whether rightly or wrongly but like
there was an um
a decision that like hey xrp is a
security is that kind of the
like maybe not the death blow but but
does that pretty much tie your hands and
make it
nearly impossible to to conduct business
in the united states or is there some
alternative path but maybe it's just
like filled with more obstacles and it's
just more difficult how do you look at
that
well look i i mean i look at it as one
member
and ripple's an important member of the
xrp community
that uh i don't it is my very strong
opinion that it's very hard to look at
xrp as a security i i've
made lots of points publicly about why
that's the case
uh i didn't think you changed your mind
on that but i just wanted to give you
the opportunity if you did but go ahead
fair enough uh you know
i i think if xrp were deemed a security
here in the united states
that you know where you have other major
g20 markets that have already
taken a different view it's kind of like
i'm not aware of
any market globally that thinks xrp is a
security
and so you know you think about all
right so why would we here in the united
states want to make a decision that's
out of sync with
other major g20 markets why would we
want to create an uneven
playing field that advantaged these
chinese control technologies
particularly frankly in a trump
administration
whatever you may think about that uh and
i i just step back and think all right
why like is this the best
path like who are we solving for and you
know
there's plenty of conspiracy theorists
that you know are out there that have
all kinds of conjectures about all kinds
of things
i just look at it and think about look
you've got a bunch of companies here in
the united states
building upon an open source technology
that isn't controlled by the u.s is
controlled by china
it is controlled by ripple we should
want to fuel and foster that we should
want to
provide the clarity the certainty the
level playing field and
uh i i don't i think that if there were
a negative determination made that would
mean that okay
in the united states people would need
to be
thinking about if you trade xrp well you
need a broker dealer license
uh yeah you also have examples which you
know like today
paypal has announced their intent to
support these things
and they have actually my understanding
is they have been relatively transparent
that
hey we're not supporting xrp at the
opening of
you know paypal support because of the
lack of regulatory clarity
well you know all right so that gives
these chinese control technologies
where the chinese communist party
certainly has
if not control heavy influence i mean
again i'll digress just simply point out
when ant financial largest ipo in
history
is delayed by the chinese communist
party let's not pretend that if the
chinese communist party
wants to provide control or oversight in
some way
of these concentrated miners in china i
think it's not that's not realistic and
again
i'm not necessarily saying let's just
acknowledge it
and let's decide okay does it matter is
it critical
let's let's not pretend it's not there
let's acknowledge that it's there
but hold on a second so there's a
difference though between
could they exert influence over minors
that are a minority part of the network
right
versus they're not a minority of course
they are there there's nobody who's got
50 plus percent control
four miners in china have well over 50
control
but that's 200 percent no sorry the
the combination of four miners have over
50 control yeah
well no they've got over 50 percent of
the mining
hash power but they don't have control
of bitcoin right it's not like the
chinese communist party can
change anything or do anything they
there are miners
control a majority of the hash power the
miners are the masters
if you control a majority of the hash
power you know we have seen 51
attacks on other blockchains if the
chinese communist party
i mean if what you're saying is you
don't think the chinese communist party
could go it to those four minors and say
hey you need to do x y and z i mean i
would
i'll ask you is that is that the
position that you're well
i'm trying to understand what your
argument is in terms of you're saying
that the chinese communist party has the
ability to essentially
51 attack the bitcoin network
one for sure they do oh i i disagree
with that for sure
all right hold on wait wait wait time
out time out time put a pin hold on
pause
we you i know you well enough and i
think you know me well enough we're not
going to change each other's mind on
this
so just put a pin in that one okay well
let me ask two questions
okay do you think the chinese communist
party could if they wanted to control
those four
miners no
but they can control the ipo of the
largest i mean like by comparison
of course no what they can do is they
can shut the miners down
right but like the chinese communist
party does not control ant financial in
terms of make the business decisions
what they did is they stopped the
listing on an exchange of course
but they control the exchange they don't
contribute if i come back to you with
like maybe
five examples where the chinese
communist party has actually
made decisions at a more micro level
but here's here's a good example hold on
if you use the ant financial example
right that would be like me saying that
the sec controls
ripple right because you just compared
the chinese communist party to the trump
administration
to the sec okay look i i don't believe
that in comparison to how the us
government works and how the chinese
government works
is a i know my point my point being that
uh when ant financial goes to conduct
ipo right
it's very very well documented that uh
jack ma said some things it sounds like
it pissed off the ccp and
there was whether directly or indirectly
uh you're not going to take the company
public right now
right was it a decision made and that
was executed the
why it happens is besides the points
just the fact that yes they stopped that
from happening
that is in my opinion no different than
if
an outside regulatory body or the
government stops you from listening on
an exchange or doing something now i
think where people have the problem is
why it happened right like imagine if
you were trying to conduct business and
if you said something that you know
upset somebody then they would come
after you type situation that wouldn't
be
a good business environment to operate
it but let's go all the way back for a
second
so if if xrp was uh
deemed kind of a negative ruling in your
opinion then
really what it does is it might not
necessarily hamper your ability to
operate globally but definitely in the
united states it would drastically
change
the way that you can operate if not even
make it nearly impossible to do it
based on how the system's built today no
i mean that's too far
okay any like look a lot of what ripple
does to the united states
we could continue no problem uh you know
a component of what we do today
is our customers of odl on demand
liquidity
they buy xrp from us if
in fact then that is a security we would
have to get a broker dealer license
anybody who's buying and selling xrp in
the united states if you get a brokerage
license
the reality is what we would probably do
is just say okay
in order to provide certainty and
clarity on a go forward basis we would
want to look at other markets
other jurisdictions where there is that
clarity and you know
earlier in this conversation i
highlighted the uk i highlighted
to japan highlighted uh singapore
these are all markets where you do have
that clarity where you can operate with
certainty and
ripple can keep you know moving forward
and i mean frankly
most of our customers are non-us
customers by a long shot today
and so uh we could absolutely continue
to build the business and grow and just
we would no longer be a u.s taxpayer we
paid you know i don't know
probably order magnitude a couple
hundred million dollars in taxes here in
the united
states and i just think that it doesn't
serve i think the u.s
agenda to uh to drive us off short
so this is a really important point i
don't i don't know if you guys publish
this number or not but
uh if you're able to share it the
percentage of customers that are us
first international
i think most people when they think of
large uh companies they think of them as
like hey they started in the united
states they penetrate the u.s market and
they kind of internationally expand
and so the u.s is usually like a big
portion of the business
crypto's a little bit different right
where companies actually like they can
be global on day one
the whole point of what you're building
is uh that
you can operate anywhere right and so uh
you
and other crypto companies naturally
have like much larger international
customer bases than just a traditional
company
is that like a 10 of customers are in
the us or more like
45 more than 90
of ripple net customers are outside the
united states wow that's a huge number
okay yeah so look it you know cause
effect and one thing's interesting here
like i don't i can't know this i'm
speculating here but like
if there was more clarity here in the
united states and
certainty would that number be different
i i don't know uh and certainly one
dynamic is we're solving a cross-border
payments problem which is
more paying for smaller economies
because you know a lot of banks a lot of
financial companies in the united states
the percentage of business they do
that's domestic payments versus non-us
payments is different look it all kind
of goes back to
we need a framework that provides this
clarity
i will highlight in a really positive
way and particularly these days not many
people are saying nice things about
what's going on in washington but you
know there's some legislation that was
introduced
before uh the election called the
digital commodity exchange act and
this would be a huge step forward in
providing regulatory clarity
and i think it would really bring the us
to kind of equal footing with some of
these other major g20
cftc i think put this forward
you know i know i'm not sure i would
attribute to the quote cftc
as much as i don't have the names right
in front of me but you know this one's
brought by a number of reps uh it i do
view this as pretty bipartisan
you know it isn't just you know hey what
do democrats think what republicans
think it's
look we need this clarity uh the bill
was introduced i think it was in the ag
committee uh and did you know it got
some traction and i think will be
revisited
if you know when uh congress comes back
in session in the spring
the reason why i mentioned the cftc is i
uh interviewed chairman tarbert
and uh we discussed it and he seemed
like relatively receptive to
that that framework let me ask this uh
if
90 95 of your customers are outside the
u.s and there's the
lack of clarity in the u.s uh is there a
world where you just say
basically you know not screw the united
states but like we're better served
uh just moving everyone outside the
united states and just like operating
the business everywhere but in the u.s
or is that too aggressive of a
uh kind of position to take
look you know i i guess randomly
mentioned before like i'm a kid from
kansas
uh we are a proud u.s company uh
our preference would be to remain a very
proud u.s company could we
operate successfully outside the united
states i think it's clear we could
uh that isn't our it i also want to be
clear
you know we get lots of stones get
thrown in the crypto community and as
you and i talked when i was with you
last time i think we all should kind of
like look all votes can rise and even in
my comments around
you know bitcoin and potential control
of the chinese communist party
i say that in a way like how do we
actually acknowledge that like what are
the implications
let's think about how we could address
that for
me it's i would like to ripple to stay a
proud u.s company
if there are uh dynamics that limit our
ability to be successful here then of
course
you know i have a fiduciary
responsibility uh you know i want to see
ripple be
as successful as possible and uh i want
to do the things that that will help
achieve that
so there's going to be a change of
administration uh it appears i'll say it
appears because uh
in 2020 i'm not going to uh think
anything is uh is official until it
happens
uh but under a biden presidency uh
does this become a better solved problem
uh or does it actually get worse like
how do you kind of think of
a trump administration of biden
administration and and what that means
for the crypto regulation
yeah it's a good question i mean i think
a lot of the stuff we have been talking
about
isn't a republican or democrat and you
know by extension i don't think
materially changes and by an
administration there's a lot of
bipartisan support
for you know using ripple's point of
view of like hey
should the us have improved underlying
financial infrastructure
i think frankly even as we saw through
the stimulus that you know the ability
to
actually have low friction ability to to
to distribute money was was challenged
so
i think it's a pretty bipartisan the two
things i think uh
may change i mean so one i do think
there's more understanding of the
potential
i'm i'm uh responding to your commentary
the potential for
china's control uh is
is a factor that i think is is rising to
the fore the second is
i think that in this i think may change
in a byte administration is the
attention and concern from an
environmental point of view
about all things environment and by
extension
understanding that today and again i'm
not say i'm long bitcoin
but understanding that today bitcoin
mining uh
obviously consumes a lot of power uh
and you know how do we think about that
you know are there ways that we
we could uh improve that i think you
know well
pumped you know ripple has worked with
regulators since the very beginning and
somewhat in the earliest days of crypto
controversially
and i don't think any administration
change here in the us is going to have a
material
impact of change it's it's a bipartisan
issue
both sides of the aisle care about
transparency for consumer protection
they care as i just i mean maybe one
side cares a little more about
environmental impact but
like i think the macro trend lines here
in the us the macro trend lines globally
are very positive for crypto and i think
that's one of the reasons why we're
seeing
you know things uh the market overall do
so well
and uh obviously with you know bitcoin
as a
bellwether uh leading that charge you
know almost
back to you know three-year highs i
think and almost all-time highs
uh i i remain very bullish yeah what
about uh jay clayton stepping down from
the
sec or like a brian brooks uh he's
temporary head of the occ right now
maybe maybe he doesn't
right nominating today yeah so what what
is kind of the
um does is there material change if
either one of those uh well jay clinton
is definitely stepping down and brian
may or may not stay
like does that have an impact or again
is this so much bigger than any one
person or one organization
uh and it really has to be kind of a
national uh
almost uh focus right to kind of get
this clarification
look i think uh i'll maybe
comment first on brian brooks i mean
under brian brooks leadership they've
taken a very pro-industry stance
uh i think yeah the occ has has
published several letters
and this is allowing banks to service
crypto companies even hold crypto and
that's a very big deal i think
i actually think some of when that was
first announced i think it was
under reported or understood if you will
uh i guess it's a really big deal and
it's very positive for the industry and
again i think if
if we believe these technologies around
crypto and blockchain
are consequential and we want to put the
us in a position to lead that next
generation
i think the the leadership from the occ
uh and under brian brooks has been a
very big deal
you know what does it mean for jay
clayton to step down i i don't know
uh you know it depends a lot on who
is coming in as the next chair and you
know what priorities they set
i hope that we find ourselves with a
clear understanding that
so far the sec has not provided a level
playing field
right in the in the the balance they put
their finger on the scale a little bit
and to advantage uh bitcoin and ether
and
by the way you have seen that since
those determinations
were made by the sec bitcoin even in the
period between bitcoin's announcement
and east announcement two and a half
years ago
bitcoin outperformed then you add eth
into the good housekeeping and east
outperform the whole market right uh and
that's
that's just logical right that makes
sense if there's clarity and certainty
and so
look i i think the sec uh has tried very
hard to
you know get the abusive activity that
was represented by the icos you know
before you and i had met i certainly was
outspoken in my belief that icos were
fraught with risk and likely to uh bring
the ire of the sec i think it did
but i i still think we haven't gotten
that clarity so that they went after the
tale of the bad actors but we haven't
really gotten that clarity at the head
of
like there's a handful of clear uh
you know assets digital assets being
used in this market and i think we
should have that
level playing field absolutely um the
last thing i want to end on
uh is probably the biggest change
between the first time we talked in now
which is uh there's a global pandemic
and uh the fed has decided to step into
markets and kind of everything that that
is uh tangentially related to kovid
how has that impacted uh both your guys
business but also
uh potentially you think the crypto
regulation
so you know look i think there's a well
understood dynamic where
a lot of trends that were you know
preceded the quarantine were already
happening i just think that the
quarantine and dynamics associated with
that have accelerated those trends and
crypto is one beneficiary of that the
move away from cash
to more digital transactions uh
certainly
the crypto market at large as a
inflationary hedge
has benefited from you know trillions of
dollars of stimulus here in the united
states and really
globally uh you know for ripple
specifically
you know we still expect growth on a
year-on-year basis one of the key
metrics we look at
is transactions on the network how many
transactions
uh and how is that growth rate and look
we expect
growth to be about five you know five x
year on year
now i will say that's not quite where we
thought we thought it would grow more
than 5x on the other hand if you say
to you know most people like hey we're
growing a 5x year on year you're like
holy [ __ ] like that's
that's fast growth so we're probably a
little bit behind where
i thought we would be so i don't want to
pretend that cobit hasn't been an impact
but look in many ways you know
remittances are as
important as ever the cost of
remittances the friction romances are as
important as ever
and i think that uh bringing that to the
fort helping people understand how
ripple is solving those problems for
banks for finance institutions for
payments i think is important
and uh you know i'm really pleased that
the team at ripple i mean it's been
incredible to see
we have 500 people worldwide and you
know just getting [ __ ] done uh
in a different environment and you know
firmly believing in the mission
uh has i think helped in that regard
absolutely
uh to close this out what do you kind of
think
should happen with the regulatory
environment is this a
um i call it a national decree like
there's one body and they can just say
hey here's the rules from now on
go forth and build what you want uh is
there
some other kind of solution that you're
looking for
no look i think the dcea would be a
perfect example
of the dca i mean the digital commodity
exchange act that i commented about
earlier it would be a major step forward
towards regulatory clarity
and i think it would provide you know
allow u.s companies to have
to be able to compete on equal footing
look i just want to keep emphasizing
we're not looking for the us government
to do something to advantage
the xrp community or to advantage ripple
specifically
all we want is an equal playing field we
want to level equal footing so that we
can compete in the market
uh side by side with the companies that
they have already
done things to advantage yeah where can
people
find you on the internet uh twitter is
probably best
at be garlinghouse all right have you
been answering tweets
i know people got to be tweeting at you
all the time
i every once about much to the
frustration of the
communications team at ripple every once
while it happens mostly when i'm on a
flight
and i'm i'm bored and i'll get on
twitter and i'll start commenting
which gives them a lot of angst that
oh what's brad saying but no i get on
there every once well look at the
challenges of course there's a lot of
uh i mean frankly it's a reflection of
the politics the united states there's a
lot of
vitriol sometimes just like okay come on
you know uh
and like i understand different people
have different perspectives
i really do believe all boats rise here
and i i spend way more time and energy
thinking about how can i help other
projects how can ripple help other
projects
i'll remind you like ripple has invested
literally hundreds of millions of
dollars
not on xrp but in other projects across
the crypto community
yeah the thing that i think
is so interesting is uh
people decide to attack or not attack uh
and sometimes um there's very good
reason and then other times there's uh
you kind of are scratching your head as
to
why why is that the good or the bad
thing um
so it's uh just a byproduct i think of
crypto in general
but uh listen brad thank you so much for
doing this um if you guys want to ask
brad questions
uh hopefully he's flying soon and he
will respond to all your tweets
i'm gonna i don't know when when you're
posting this but i've got a
if i get a slow afternoon i'll go in
there and reply to a bunch all right so
if you guys want tweet it brad i'll send
him an email before we uh before we post
it he'll be ready to go
for uh we will obviously be super kind
and uh and very thoughtful love letters
uh but try to uh try to ask serious
questions and hopefully
you guys get some answers that i didn't
ask brad listen thank you so much for
doing this
and we will have to do it again my
friend all right good to see you go
kansas